[Applaudissements]
ils nous font peur
ils volent notre travail nous sommes
désemparés ils ce sont les algorithmes
elles ce sont les machines qu'ils
apprennent comprennent et nous
surprennent nous ce sont les humains
membre du collectif de notre espèce
alors comme dignement
je vous salue fraternellement dont les
algues vertes et je vis dans un pays en
espagne où nous avons connu récemment
des émeutes sans précédent d'une
violence inouïe des émeutes
en réaction à une société que nous avons
construite dans laquelle l'homme va
devoir partager son présent et son futur
son talent et son ego avec des machines
avec des algorithmes avec de
l'intelligence artificielle et avec des
objets connectés
la question qui m'interpelle à moi la
question que je nous pose aujourd'hui
c'est pourquoi pourquoi avons nous peur
pourquoi réagir avec autant de véhémence
contre des créations intellectuelles
contre des objets qui ont le potentiel
de résoudre les problèmes les plus ardus
les plus épineux aujourd'hui et demain
alors comme il s'agit d'une question
brûlante mais délicieuse j'appelle sur
ce plateau
l'ambassadrice du bon goût et du bon
sens
la grande prêtresse des petits fours
nous j'appelle ginette mathiot
ginette mathiot sais pas si vous la
connaissez mais c'est une dame qui a
écrit un livre qui s'appelle je sais
cuisiner pour vous dire un petit secret
quand j'ai quitté la maison à 18 ans ma
maman m'a donné un exemplaire de la
relique et elle m'a dit bon vent et bon
goût
j'en ai pris bonne note mais ginette
mathiot ginette pour les amis un secret
ginette durant toute sa vie à créer
tester et publier des centaines
d'algorithmes d'algues au coin
algorithmes en effet ce mot barbare nous
vient du nom d'un mathématicien persan
al khwarizmi il veut dire tout
simplement une méthode ordonné non
ambiguë de résoudre des problèmes ou une
famille de problème waouh ça c'est cool
et ça c'est cool c'est vraiment cool et
vous savez pourquoi
parce que nous les humains du matin
jusqu'au soir de l'enfance à la
vieillesse
nous devons pour exister vivre et
survivre résoudre des problèmes on peut
les résoudre en chantant en en s'amusant
en pleurant on doit le résoudre et le
dernier problème qu'on n'arrive pas à
résoudre nous envoie dans la caisse par
conséquent je vous invite
fraternellement une nouvelle fois à
cultiver votre talent pour résoudre des
problèmes comme vous l'aurez compris
j'adore les algorithmes j'adore les
algorithmes parce qu'ils sont comme cet
objet vivant coloré surprenant bruyant
diabolique et dans tous les cas
passionnant mais les énergies
c'est que ses algorithmes permettent
dans mon travail dans mes relations avec
les autres de comprendre le monde dans
lequel je vis d'interagir avec les
autres et de créer des belles choses des
relations des découvertes des
publications des projets des entreprises
mille chose qui m'excite
alors aujourd'hui je voudrais profiter
de votre présence pour faire un petit
voyage au fil des algorithmes pour
découvrir tous ensemble qui nous sommes
où allons nous et de quoi sera fait
demain
pas mal mais bon on va essayer la
première chose qui est intéressante avec
les algorithmes c'est qu'ils sont
partout ils nous entoure il nous
accompagne
il nous guide nous emmerdent des fois un
par exemple pour construire des maisons
on utilise le théorème de pythagore de
pythagore un algorithme très simple pour
naviguer sur internet pagerank
l'algorithme de google pour trouver
votre moitié sur kindle un autre
algorithme et enfin pour créer de la
confiance la fameuse bloc chain et
ginette mathiot on a écrit plein
d'autres vous savez maintenant
la deuxième chose qui est fascinante
avec les algorithmes c'est que au pays
des biologistes ce sont les
mathématiciens et les physiciens en
parlent le mieux
je vous parlais apajh ynet de léonard
leonhard euler un grand mathématicien
pour lequel j'ai une énorme admiration
il motive il me surprend il m'intéresse
malgré qu'il soit né au xviiie siècle
il a fait des choses merveilleuses est
pour moi une des choses les plus simples
et les plus belles qu'il est fait c'est
donner une définition de la quantité le
dire une quantité c'est un panier avec
des haricots
c'est des oeufs dans une boîte lui il
prend le contre-pied tout ça elle dit
une quantité c'est quelque chose qui
peut augmenter ou diminuer
c'est à dire que c'est un problème dans
lequel on s'occupe de maintenir quelque
chose dans un intervalle de valeur et
vous reconnaîtrez tous un logis sous nos
yeux le east le concept d' homeostasis
dormir strasbourg en france
je passe maintenant un physicien erwin
schrödinger très connu pour son équation
d'onde
moins connue pour son ménage à trois
parce qu'il a fait le trio le plus
scandaleux de la moitié du 20e siècle
son couple était un problème à trois
corps régis par la relation
d'incertitude
je le félicite 1 erwin schrödinger
en plus de son équation écrit un livre
qui s'appelle qu'est ce que la vie je
vous le conseille sur un livre
prodigieux écrit dans les années 40 avec
une certaine un petit décalage pour
l'instant mais ces idées sont profondes
et lui définit la vie comme deux choses
un code pour stocker de l'information
est un ensemble de mécanismes qui
permettent de lutter contre le deuxième
principe de la thermodynamique le
désordre
donc en fait la vie c'est localement la
création d'ordre au moins deux
structures une idée très belle comme le
roi n'est pas mon cousin
je me permet aujourd'hui de proposer ma
propre version
avant de proposer une version j'ai
oublié cette petite est positif est très
intéressante
non seulement les algorithmes nous
entourent dans les objets dans la vie de
tous les jours de manière aussi dans la
nature lorsque vous envoyez un message à
internet à votre chéri y aurait eu le
message ne voyage pas d'un seul paquet
il est coupé en petits morceaux
envoyé par des chemins différentes votre
chéri et où il reçoit le message le
recomposent et s'émeut de votre gentil
pensée ou non 1 qu'est ce qui se passe
là dedans on appelle ce protocole
protocole c'est un ensemble
d'algorithmes tcp ip
vous avez tous entendu par les adresses
ip et bien tcpc une partie ipc l'autre
partie tcpc la partie qui donne routage
qui dit voilà ici et des embouteillages
n'enverra plus d'informations ici c'est
libre renvoyé tout le pack sp1 et bien
les fourmis lorsqu'elles partent de la
fourmilière pour chercher leur
nourriture
elle utilise pardon un algorithme qui
est identique à tcp c'est à dire
qu'elles sortent chacun de leur côté par
des chemins différents
la première qui découvrent dans la
nourriture s'arrête ne la mange pas
surtout pas retourner en arrière trace
un chemin simic et dit à ses collègues
venez par là il ya du miam miam et donc
dans un canal internet d'entre eux car
on a internet
cette merveilleuse découverte nous
montre que les algorithmes sont au coeur
du vivant au coeur de qui nous sommes
deux d'où nous venons et 2 où nous
allons et pourquoi en est il ainsi
probablement parce que la vie c'est la
manière de résoudre les mêmes défauts
elle convie stationnaire et donc par
conséquent les algorithmes que nous
créons où la vie août évolué de manière
convergente vers la résolution de
problèmes le mathématicien henri
poincaré avec cette phrase magnifique il
disait les mathématiques c'est la
manière de dire la même chose de donner
pardon le même nom à des choses
différentes
c'est exactement ça alors voilà un
algorithme égale problème
computationnelle basé sur cette
expérience comme je les dis je me
permets après l air et je râle inger
avec toute la modestie qui me
caractérise de proposer ma propre
définition du vivant pour moi et vivent
une chose qui a trois caractéristiques
la première une capacité de contacts et
de parler et d'échanger avec les autres
la deuxième une capacité comme on a vue
de résoudre des problèmes
computationnelle qu'est ce que ça veut
dire computationnelle ça veut dire qu'on
peut réaliser des calculs des opérations
de la logique des choses comme ça et
finalement le troisième point très
important c'est la capacité de se
répliquer d'évoluer donc de changer et
surtout de s'auto actualisé ça c'est un
mot moche mais que tous les windows
attention j'ai besoin de minutes pour
motos actualisé ne l'interrompe pas
c'est très important et ce qui me plaît
ma définition
si vous me permettez un peu fier de moi
mais c'est comme ça 1 c'est que on peut
caractériser les êtres vivants les êtres
non vivant comme les virus mais aussi
les machines
lorsque vous amenez votre voiture au
garage
votre mécanicien la branche sur internet
actualise son software décharge les
sorts de pneus descend de consommation
vous fait un bilan votre voiture est à
changer chercher un financement ou votre
voiture est très bien continuer avec la
marque et sedrun mais donc ça ça m'amène
un concept intéressant
ces concepts de machin nous contre les
machines parce qu'en fait nous ne sont
un peu comme les objets connectés
de temps en temps on échange on fait des
copains des copines on parle on évolue
et on établit une auto actualisation
lorsqu'on étudie comme vous ou lorsqu un
moment de sa vie on envie de faire autre
chose
réapprendre se remettre en question
effacés du passé faisons table rase etc
etc et là vient à mon avis un des trois
problèmes que nous avons avec les
machines
elise a parlé tout à l'heure de la
pyramide de maslow qui en fait est un
théoricien un psychologue qui a étudié
les besoins humains et tout au sommet de
la pyramide se trouve l'auto
actualisation saviez que jusqu'à présent
on a vécu très bien parce que les
machines était idiote des machines nous
avait créé pour se défaire de ce que
nous ne voulions pas faire aujourd'hui
elles nous font le lit mais en
portefeuille et donc ça c'est douloureux
ça je pense que c'est une des raisons
principales pour laquelle nous avons un
problème avec les machines nous les
machins le deuxième problème que je vois
c'est que aujourd'hui nous sommes nous
avons un défi dans les années 40
le joueur d'échecs pour lui demander
mais monsieur vous êtes champion du
monde d'échecs vous êtes vraiment un
prodige et lui avec son cigare de whisky
mais comment ce que vous faites quel est
votre truc combien de mouvements êtes
vous capable de prédire à l'avancé
il avait cette réponse que je trouve
délicieuse il disait moi je résous je
prévois seulement un mouvement mais
c'est toujours le bon et donc on est
passé de cette arrogance délicieuse on
va dire à biarritz par aof
cinq fois champion du monde ou plusieurs
fois champion du monde un prodige des
échecs créatif combatif agressif une
star une personne impressionnante aussi
pas aussi bien par sa psychologie
son jeu par son nom sa connaissance
encyclopédique des échecs que par ça un
capacités dans les médias et bien garry
kasparov en 82 à jouer contre un
ordinateur qui s'appelle double où vous
savez tous il s'est ramassé une
déculottée il est rentré chez lui la
queue entre les jambes
c'est pas grave mais c'était déjà un
changement il y à peu lisse idol qui est
un une figure vivante d'hugo legault est
un jeu qui est peut-être énormément plus
complexe que le les échecs au niveau
combinatoire et donc les gens pensaient
que il était impossible au niveau de la
combinatoire et au niveau de la halle
des mathématiques est là derrière de
battre un champion humains au go
simplement parce que c'est pas
uniquement delà du calcul mathématique
il a de l'intuition
il ya du got a feeling il y adeux l'un
de l'expérience il y à du risque et tout
ça on pensait que l'homme le faisait
mieux que tout le monde
résultat les courses 4 pour la machine 1
pour monsieur si dole ça fait mal ça
fait mal parce que non seulement nous
avons créé ces jeux nous avons créé ces
machines et en venant avec notre
réputation notre culture nos croyances
comme disait stéphane on s'en prend
plein la gueule
hélas pour moi c'est le deuxième point
qui fait que nous sommes allergiques aux
machines un problème d'ego donc on a
parlé un loto utilisation les machines
font aussi bien que nous lego et puis
aussi un je pense qu'il ya un vrai
problème de concurrence
concurrence déloyale jusqu'à présent on
a confié en nous notre créativité et
notre humanité à notre fraternité pour
vivre pour créer pour interagir pour
être heureux et puis on a vu que dans
des tâches aussi bête que conduire une
voiture est bien les machines nous
dépasse lorsque
tesla à commercialiser sa première
voiture automatique électrique les
humains qui sont rentrés dedans on fait
dans leur pantalon parce que la voiture
qu'on disait tellement bien et tellement
vite que les humains n'étaient pas
habitués qu'est ce que ça veut dire tout
ça ça veut dire que les machines peuvent
découvrir des solutions bien meilleure
que celle qu'on a trouvé jusqu'à présent
et ça c'est effrayant alors voilà qu'est
ce qu'on doit faire collaborer comme le
disent et lise entrer en concurrence
comme le font certains donné les coups
de tatane contre les taxis c'est une
solution se comporter comme un i'm un
animal mais en fait le chauffeur de taxi
qui donne une tatane aux chauffeurs de
hubert ou de kabyles faille en espagne
c'est une victime et c'est une victime
qui se comporte comme un agresseur et
pour moi ce n'est vraiment pas la bonne
solution
moi je crois en la fraternité je crois
dans personne et je crois que le
problème ne vient pas de l'algorithme
vient de notre usage
lorsqu'on commande une pizza 1 qu'on
amène à la maison alors qu en train de
regarder le foot dans le sofa on s'en
fout que le livreur de pizza gagne 1
euro pouvoir fait 17 km en vélo on s'en
tape
c'est pas un problème je pense qu'on
n'est pas habitué au jour d'aujourd'hui
à apprendre que les choses changent que
les révolutions ne se font pas sans
couper des têtes que le changement fait
mal on n'est pas habitué à remettre en
cause notre confort n'est pas habitué à
changer de choses en fait ce qui arrive
aux chauffeurs de taxi qui donne un coup
de tatane dans la voiture c'est que on
l'a réveillé pendant la sieste
et pendant qu'ils dormaient quelqu'un
aux états unis qui ne le connaissait ni
d'eve ni d'adam a eu l'idée d'un
algorithme et d'un modèle d'affaires qui
va complètement mettre en péril son
business qui va mettre en péril son
confort sa manière elle
en d'autres termes il a arrêté de penser
et je ne m'en réjouis pas mais je pense
sincèrement que c'est inéluctable
alors au lieu d'être une victime soyons
pensons organisons nous réagissons
réagissons de manière créative
fraternelle et constructif alors je
voudrais terminer en vous souhaitant à
tous un futur plein de machines
sympathique et plein d'autres actions
fraternelle merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]